♪ ♪
>> Laura: SOME REPUBLICANS
HAVE SHIED AWAY FROM FOCUSING ON
CLOSE TROLL ISSUES AN ELECTION
YEAR OUT OF FEAR THAT IT WILL
ALIENATE SOME VOTERS.
ALONG WITH THE ECONOMY HOT
BUTTON SOCIAL ISSUES THEY'RE
DRIVING A LOT OF THE POLITICAL
ENERGY THE CYCLE.
SO THE PUSHING RADICAL SOCIAL
AGENDAS ARE PUSHING RESIDENTS OF
THE LIMIT.
SOME EVEN FLING TO RED STATES
FOR A REPRIEVE FROM ALL OF THIS.
IN OTHER WORDS PEOPLE ARE
VOTING.
WHEN THEIR SUBSCRIPTION DOLLARS
AS WELL.
OR TALK ABOUT NETFLIX THEY'VE
LOST A LOT OF SUBSCRIBERS, NOT
ONE REASON FOR THIS WERE NOT TO
TO DIAGNOSE IT.
BUT THAT IT'S A AS WELL THEY
LOST A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT DUE
TO PULLING OUT.
THEY ALSO PROJECTED TO LOSE
ANOTHER 2 MILLION NEXT QUARTER.
SO WHAT IS DRIVING THIS?
HAVE THEY HAD THE SERVANT
NATURAL FEELING OR IS THIS A
CULTURAL BATTLE PLAYING OUT
BEFORE OUR EYES AT LEAST IN
PART, ELON MUSK IS BETTING ON
THE LATTER OF THE SUBSCRIBER
DROP THE WOKE MIND AND BY WHICH
IS UNWATCHABLE.
I TURN NOT TO SEE THAT IT'S A
SHOVING AT LEAST SOME OF IT
WHILE MY NOT CONTRIBUTE TO ALL
OF THE DECLINE IT SURE AS HECK
IS CONTRIBUTING TO THE LAST OF
EXPANSION AT THE VERY LEAST.
THERE IS DON'T LOOK UP THE
STAR-STUDDED CLIMATE CHANGE
MOVIE ABOUT A WORLD KILLING
CLIMATE.
>> IF THERE'S A 100% CHANCE THAT
WERE ALL GOING TO DIE.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> IT'S BARRELING ITS WAY
TOWARDS EARTH DON'T YOU SEE IT?
>> Laura: OR THESE OFFERINGS?
>> GROWN UP WITH MY PARENTS I
THOUGHT HE WAS AND LOSE HIS
MIND.
YOU TOO GOOD?
>> FINE THANKS.
>> DEAD I'M GOOD TOO THANKS.
>> YOU CAN FIT IT ANYWHERE.
I WILL FIT IN ANYWHERE.
>> WHITE PEOPLE COUNTING DOWN
UNTIL THE GRADE I GRADUATE.
>> Laura: MAYBE THE LESSON IS
THIS.
WHEN A COMPANY CATERS TO
ETIOLOGY WHICH IS AN AGENDA JUST
THE NEEDS AND WANTS AND DESIRES
OF ITS CONSUMERS THERE GONNA
SUFFER AS NETFLIX HUMBLES THIS
OVER THE PAST YEAR NO DOW STOCK
HAS PERFORMED WORSE THAN THIS.
WERE TIRED ABOUT DISNEY THEIR
DROP.
JOIN WITH ME PRAGER YOU
PERSONALITY AND FORMER LEFT-WING
ACTIVISTS BETWEEN DISNEY'S DOW
DROP IN THE SUBSCRIBER DROP OF
NETFLIX THERE'S SOMETHING
HAPPENING HERE WITH YOUR
THOUGHTS ON IT?
>> I THINK IT'S JUST WOKE MIND
VIRUS AND THEIR WAKING UP AND
INOCULATING THEMSELVES FROM IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR THIS
ANYMORE AND NETFLIX IS KNOWN TO
BE DOING THIS.
THEY PUT OUT A FRENCH FILM
CALLED CUTIES WITH 11-YEAR-OLD
GIRLS WITH BARELY ANY CLOTHES
ON.
TORQUING AND SHAKING THEIR ON
FILM.
THEY HAVE A SERIES CALLED YOU
WHERE THEY DENOUNCE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ANTI-COVERT VACCINES,
THEY'RE FULL OF PROPAGANDA OF
THE PRESCRIBED THEMSELVES TO
ANTI-WHITENESS ANTIRACISM,
RADICAL FEMINISM AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY PUT IN THEIR CONTENT.
YOU CAN'T FIND A PIECE OF NEFF
WAS CONTENT THAT DOES NOT HAVE
LEFTIST IDEOLOGY EMBEDDED IN IT
AND I THINK PEOPLE ARE FED UP
WITH IT THEY DON'T PAY A MONTHLY
FEE TO BE LIED TO AND TO BE SAID
PROPAGANDA AND TO BE TOLD THAT
THEY ARE HATED.
SO I THINK THAT'S WHY
SUBSCRIBERS ARE LEAVING IN MASS
BUT IF YOU LIKE THIS OTHER
COMPUTING FACTORS.
>> Laura: THE FACT IS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE LIMITED DOLLARS TO
SPEND.
AND IT'S LIKE YOU DON'T WANT TO
GO INTO A BAR IF THE BARTENDER
IS JUST GONNA SCREAM AT YOU AND
OBSCENITIES AT YOU AND SEE HOW
MUCH HE HATES YOU.
YOU GO TO A DIFFERENT BAR.
SO IF YOU CAN STREAM OTHER
CONTENT WHERE YOU CAN STREAM
NETFLIX IF INDEED YOU BELIEVE
TOO MUCH OF IT, I'M NOT SAYING
ALL THE CONTENT.
BUT TOO MUCH OF THE CONTENT IS
EITHER FORTIFIED OR JUST
DIRECTLY POLITICAL.
HERE'S A COMMENT FROM 2019 FROM
NETFLIX'S CEO WATCH.
>> AS A CONSEQUENCE OF SLAVERY,
JIM CROW AND HOUSING POLICIES,
BLACK FAMILIES IN AMERICA
ONE-TENTH OF THE WEALTH.
IF EVERY MAJOR CORPORATION TAKES
1% OF THEIR CASH AND DEPOSITS IT
IN A BLACK BAG IT WILL BE
TRANSFORMATIVE IN THAT SECTOR.
>> Laura: HE MADE A PLEA FOR
REPARATIONS, HE DIDN'T USE THE
WORD FOR REPARATIONS.
BUT I CAN IMAGINE THAT ONE OVER
WELL WITH SOME OF THE
SHAREHOLDERS.
>> NO AND NOT AT ALL IT'S NOT
BEING ABLE TO CONSUMERS OF
NETFLIX AS WELL.
I WAS A BLACK PERSON DO NOT WANT
TO HEAR THIS DEMEANING MESSAGE
ABOUT HOW I NEED HELP FROM YOU.
AND HOW I NEED HELP FROM THE
RICH AND HOW WE NEED TO INVEST
IN BLACK BUSINESS.
WHAT IS NETFLIX DOING FOR BLACK
PEOPLE OR FOR LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES, VIRTUALLY NOTHING.
WHEN THIS BLACK LIVES MATTER
SCANDAL BROKE OUT PEOPLE WERE
TAKING TO THE TREATS WHAT
NETFLIX DO?
THE "CATEGORY ON THE STREAMING
SERVICE FOR BLACK CREATORS AND
BLACK CONTENT.
NOT ONLY SEGREGATING THEIR
CONSUMERS AND CREATING A
DIVISIVE CLIMATE, BUT DOING
NOTHING FOR BLACK PEOPLE IN
THEIR EFFORTS.
IT MADE NO SENSE, IT'S ALL
VIRTUE SIGNALING AND IT'S ALL
PROPAGANDA THAT'S ALL THAT THEY
WANT.
>> Laura: WHAT'S WRONG WITH
HAVING A BLACK WRITERS ARE BLACK
PRODUCERS CATEGORY?
>> WE DON'T NEED TO BE UPLIFTED
IT SORT OF COMES WITH THIS
MESSAGE OF THIS SOFT BIGOTRY OF
LOW EXPECTATIONS THAT BECAUSE
THAT YOU ARE A BLACK CREATOR WE
NEED TO LIFT YOU UP, WE NEED TO
SEPARATE AND CREATE SOME
DEVIATION BETWEEN YOU AND OTHER
PEOPLE.
YOU CANNOT FIX SEGREGATION WITH
MORE SEGREGATION